why we want people to think that we are
normal
many of us most of us spend an
inordinate amount of time trying to
appear normal
we lie or mitt persuade and cajole not
out of some nefarious ulterior motive
but out of sheer terror that the people
around us might find out quite how odd
we truly are
[Music]
it's not that web bad or deceptive it's
simply that the thoughts which traverse
our mind sound absolutely nothing like
what the seemingly same humans we meet
every day would ever think a hundred
thousand years ago on the plains of
Africa rejection or isolation by the
tribe meant death we needed to have our
thoughts and actions confirmed
reinforced and encouraged by those
around us or else we would be exiled to
die on our own the truth is that much of
what exists in the dark recesses of our
minds would be too subtle contrary or
alarming to be consumed by society at
large and given a choice between honesty
and acceptability most of us choose the
latter we live in perpetual fear that
the people who know our outer voice
would ever get to hear what is happening
inside of our heads we're worried that
they would discover our fears regarding
where we should put our hands when were
standing talking to someone
well that strange way that we put our
hats on in the morning or the fact that
sometimes we think about poking a child
in the eye when we're talking to them
but we are no longer into gatherers we
don't require universal acceptance from
those around us the Lions are not at the
door
as my friend Jorge Miguel says embracing
being weird is a superpower I am
astounded by how many people want to be
spectacular in life but also want to be
cool and normal by being normal you are
by definition regressing to the mean
ordinary people get ordinary results
extraordinary people get extraordinary
results so the next time you have a
subtle thought and you're in a safe
environment have the courage of your
convictions and Voisin and if the
recipient turns and looks at you with
wide-eyed shock indifferent blankness or
a mocking sneer remember that this
doesn't spell doom for you and your
genes it simply means that you haven't
yet found someone who is quite you're
kind of weird
you